so nice of you to stop by kevin enjoy
your day i hope it's productive thank
you raymond i hope your day is
productive as well
pda in the office my my i couldn't help
myself hmm
oh may i please use the precinct
facilities before i head to work yes
thank you for asking for permission
thank you for granting it
womp there it is gotta say i could have
used a little more oomph on the woman
that's the emptiest we'll go again so
what's going on why do you want to mean
private i need your help with the case
three antique coins were stolen from my
classics department at columbia so why
not ask captain holt for help on the
case
wait are you guys getting a divorce i
can handle it this doesn't bring up any
weird issues for me
no it's nothing like that raymond's a
brilliant detective it's just when a
case involves me he can get a little
over-emotional you remember the safe
house oh yeah he went crazy but i also
remember you and me becoming best
friends and watching every nick cage
movie ever made can you still quote them
all no i purged myself of that nonsense
i bet it's still in there that's nice
there's a chance it's in there i'd put
money that maybe it's there you're
losing your money okay so
will you help me i don't know i want to
but keeping a secret from holt that's a
lot of pressure hmm am i remembering
correctly don't you
eat pressure for breakfast oh nick cage
in the rock we
are best friends i am so in oh no that's
raymond that's how he opens a door kevin
are you still in here uh yes raymond
i'm in the stall uh some tickets were
just released for mahler's fourth
symphony this weekend great that sounds
great let's do it fantastic now which
section do you prefer
the first tier the second tier
the third tier the first here now which
section of the first tier
right left right center
center just any section is fine any
section well someone had pepper on their
eggs this morning i'll buy the tickets
any section
[Music]
hey there
[Music]
where is kevin don't worry he's safe
look captain
i just want to say that i'm sorry you
should be
you should have abided by my security
rules you're right but i want you to
know i didn't take kevin to the library
because i was stir
crazy it's because i didn't want you
guys to get divorced how
is that any concern of yours i don't
know i just
i've been around so many failed
marriages in my life you know first
my mom and my dad and charles and
eleanor
hitchcock and brandy hitchcock and
francine hitchcock and brandy again
hitchcock and madison madison wasn't his
daughter but he dropped her off at
college last fall i know it was really
gross but the point is
i just couldn't stand to see you two
fall apart
perhaps i should have been more
understanding what kevin was going
through
i may die here tonight and his last
memory of me will be how miserable i
made him
so peralta what do you have to say for
yourself
the whole nypd knows where you are and
they're coming for you right now
okay thanks for the tip let's kill them
both get out of here before the cops
come wait no no no no i was lying about
the backup i came alone titled my sex
tape doesn't matter
you're both gonna die now
better get some corticosteroids to treat
that laryngeal fracture
sorry i couldn't bring myself to call
him a dirt bag and why would you a
dirtbag is a very useful part of the
vacuum cleaner
clearly it's a compliment oh you guys
are so perfect for each other
yeah i stole those coins i can't believe
you bought that old story they
underestimated you randy just as they
underestimated raymond holt uh you guys
haven't been that great to me either
well you got to teach people how you
want to be treated randy dr phil r.i.p
the point is captain holt solved the
case when no one else could he's
actually been stealing from these
archives for years you've been asleep at
the wheel alistair you're an
embarrassment really well at least i've
never confused scent or gusting with
boethius oh who gives a rat's ass about
boethius wesley what are you doing kevin
i'm creating a kerfuffle oh damn
sure my husband is a hot piece of ass
but he is so much more than just that
raymond holt is as smart as anyone in
this department but he chooses to use
his intelligence
to make our city a better place
one day i hope to live up to the
standard you set you make me want to
have
a wetter brain i'm kevin
[Music]
y'all are hella specific hello kevin so
uh here's an
update on sheamus thanks to our little
operation the fbi
was able to roll up his entire
organization they're saying
it's gonna be one of the most
significant ricoh prosecutions they've
ever done
amazing it's over now he can't hurt me
or kevin thank you
for titting my tat well thank you for
tatting my tit
and you know in a weird way i'm gonna
miss our little house yes and in an even
weirder way i think i might actually
miss you huh
and in an even weirder way i want you
guys to be my dads that
is weirder yeah i got stuff i uh brought
you your box of dvds huh
thank you oh forgot about this one
we never watched captain corelli's
mandolin what the hell did you just say
captain carly's mandolin say that to my
face
captain carol's panel there was a movie
about a mandolin and you kept it from me
for two
months i didn't think it was any good
it's just some period piece what set in
greece
oh my gosh based on some dumb book
terribly sorry
it has been a very trying time yeah next
thing you're gonna say you wish we had
watched leaving las vegas a dark
ponderous reflection on alcoholism that
earned cages oscar
ah what i told you the guy's got range
i refuse to put kevin in harm's way
understood but i think maybe
i have a way to put kevin in danger
without putting kevin in danger
well hello there raymond teach me kevin
and i am detective jacob peralta he
didn't have anything else to wear so he
just switched
he understands okay if we're gonna pull
this off we need to teach you how to
move
talk and act exactly like kevin in other
words we have ourselves a pygmalion
situation
exactly a pig mailman situation right
it'll be okay well it'll be okay let's
get started yes
let's get started it's getting worse
spot on kevin
look raymond a yellow-crusted warbler a
greymund
a yellow-crested warbler no you're too
excited the warbler is a common bird
and then i said which metamorphosis
kafka or
ovid i loved it he loves it oh
so that's the joke now you tell it oh
okay so
a professor walks into a rare books
collection no you've ruined it
no it's not funny look raymond a
yellow-crested warbler look raymond a
yellow-crusted word
ugh not excited enough they may be
common but they're still
birds the 92nd street y had a wonderful
symposium on just that topic
that's it you're getting it ah
don't say cool instead say indeed oh
indeed indeed indeed indeed indeed
that's weird look raymond a
yellow-crusted warbler yes
that's the right level of excitement for
such a bird you captured the essence of
kevin
you've done it correction i've
accomplished it
indeed indeed indeed
it's growing on me gina i know you like
champagne with a drop of pomegranate
juice
i like to say it's nature's classiest
alcohol mixed with its
nastiest fruit and peralta i hope this
will do
it's a can of orange soda from when some
other children visited it's perfect
thank you for inviting us in yes i
invited gina in you were
with her okay look everyone's blaming me
for the captain's horrible mood because
of a small thing that happened wednesday
morning when you flooded his office with
cider
well the water actually flooded it the
cider just caused it but i swear
he was already upset when he got to work
he was anger articulating
coat coat jacket coat is this a police
precinct
all a turkish bazaar hmm yes i dread
those enunciated denunciations
yeah i hate those dubuntu base and the
vertigo but so my question is
could something have happened at home
before he left for work well i
remember that morning he left this house
at seven and was in a great mood
in fact he was still chuckling about the
previous night's charlie rose fine so
your marriage might not be the problem
but he didn't get to work until ten that
means whatever ruined his mood happened
in those three hours
we have to retrace his steps we i'm not
going to investigate my own husband
uh-huh totally well that was a great
chit chat don't you think gina
seemed like it went real bad for you
[ __ ] chat
oh you know kevin maybe if we figure out
what
caused raymond's bad mood we could fix
it great idea gina
i suppose we could look into it yes
great
let's go right now no time to lose don't
look just run you're trying to get me
out of here before i see the orange soda
you spilled on that chair aren't you i'm
already out the door it worked is the
captain home
no good i figured out what happened to
him he was
mugged what he told you this no i used
my detective skills as well as my spot
on holt impression to figure it out i
retraced his steps and found security
footage
after he left fencing three shady guys
followed him into an alley one of them
had a knife
that's why he's been in such a bad mood
he's a police captain that got mugged
he's embarrassed
oh my goodness there he is what are you
doing in my house raymond
you were mugged what what did you say to
him
captain it's okay there's nothing to be
embarrassed about i'm not embarrassed
and i wasn't mugged
three men tried to mug me but i fought
them off injuring two of them
wait so you heroically fought off three
guys and that puts you in a bad mood
if i did that i would literally write a
song about myself it would be like
jake the hero abs of steel
why would you keep this from me and why
would you lie about going to fencing
because he couldn't go because he's
injured
i wasn't injured i was lightly stabbed
i'm sorry you were stabbed
you